hello bonjour Robert Rochefort député
donc européen du MoDem est-ce que vous
avez dû vous le livre de ce nouveau
ministre donc des finances Yanis va
oufakis
mais j'en ai entendu poser vous savez ce
qu'il y a dedans qu'est-ce que vous
pensez vous que les Européens vont
trouver un accord avec les Grecs sur
cette lettre je pense que ce matin il
s'est dit deux choses la première c'est
classiquement comme ça vient d'être dit
pourquoi faudrait-il que les Européens
payent pour la grève la Grèce la dette
qui serait éventuellement
ceci est un ceci est une pétition de
principe parce que il est exact que la
dette telle qu'elle était pas soutenable
pour les Grecs mais le deuxième sujet
qui est peut-être le plus important et
qui n'a pas par contre pas été évoqué
c'est qu'est-ce que les Grecs vont faire
comme réforme à l'intérieur de leur pays
pour eux-mêmes je crois que là où il
faut pas se tromper c'est que les
difficultés de la Grèce ne viennent pas
de l'Europe les difficultés de la Grèce
viennent de la graisse elle-même dans le
passé on en a parlé avec tous les
trucages des comptes mais également dans
le passé d'efforts non dans le passé
extrêmement récent ils ont appliqué
bêtement une politique d'austérité mais
sans justice sociale en face en
particulier vous savez bien qu'on a
maintenu les exonérations fiscales de
tout un tas de structures en particulier
de l'église en Grèce et donc on ne peut
pas imposer un peuple de l'austérité
sans de la justice mais le manque de
justice ne vient pas que de l'Europe il
vient des Grecs quand même donc avec ces
raisins ça va s'arranger non pas
forcément parce que je crois que ce que
fait cerisa est là c'est ça que ça c'est
là où le sujet va intervenir quand on
réaugmente le SMIC je ne dis pas que
c'est pas justifié pour les gens qui
touchent l'argent qui touchent peu
d'argent quand on recrute de nouveau des
fonctionnaires est-ce qu'on s'assure
pour autant que l'économie grecque va
redevenir compétitive ou pas parce que
c'est pas l'allègement de la revenu
quand même
compétitivités elle était en train de
commencer à sortir de la pure récession
donc la question qui se pose ce n'est
pas la question de on va on va
renégocier la dette vous avez d'ailleurs
vu que en Europe il y a même pas eu de
vrais soubresauts sur les bourses par
rapport au fait ça veut dire qu'il va y
avoir un arrangement parce que c'était
prévu parce que c'est pas une dette qui
est colossale et puis parce que on a
plein de curseurs on peut jouer sur
plein de choses on peut jouer sur le
taux d'intérêt on peut jouer sur ce
qu'on appelle la maturité de la dette
c'est-à-dire l'allonger encore et on
peut jouer sur l'effacement d'une partie
de la dette vous avez compris que
lorsque Monsieur sapin dit qu'on peut
pas supprimer la dette il dit en creux
on peut la réduire parce que sinon il
aurait dit on ne peut ni la supprimer ni
la réduire alors finalement tout cela va
permettre à un arrangement parce que le
risque est trop grand pour tout le monde
que ça se passe mal il peut y avoir un
arrangement mais encore une fois la
solution elle viendra des Grecs et la
question fondamentale qui se pose c'est
comment l'économie grecque redémarre
donc dans Syriza il y a une bonne
nouvelle c'est le fait de faire des
réformes de justice sociale il y a une
nouvelle qui est moins évidente c'est
comment on relance l'économie engrais
elle-même alors on de l'Europe justement
un peu plus largement les prix qui
diminuent de 0,6% en janvier dans la
zone euro une baisse de 0,2 en décembre
ça fait donc deux fois de suite des
baisses ça peut être considéré comme le
début d'une déflation en tout cas de
menace de déflation qui persiste
c'est-à-dire la baisse des prix sur une
période prolongée qui entraîne à son
tour on le sait une baisse des salaires
puis de la consommation le chômage ça va
légèrement mieux léger recul en décembre
je parle toujours de la zone euro mais
il y a quand même 18 millions de
personnes
si c'est ça que vous voulez faire
l'Europe ne va pas bien la question
c'est de savoir une amélioration c'est
de savoir si on va un petit peu mieux
quand même alors il y a deux ou trois
choses positives la première c'est que
Monsieur Draghi alors Monsieur Draghi
c'est pas le sauveur du peuple européen
mais il a quand même fait son job avec
ce qu'on sait depuis quelque jours le
rachat massif de dette souveraine à côté
ça il y a Monsieur Juncker monsieur
Juncker il essaye de faire un plan
d'investissement et là c'est bien
différent de ce que vous aimez monsieur
Barroso on sait qu'en Europe il faut
trois choses pour que ça reparte faut
premièrement un plan d'investissement un
plan d'investissement avec du
financement j'aimerais d'ailleurs que
les États l'Allemagne mais aussi la
France mais plus de sous dans le pot
commun puisque en particulier il aurait
autorisé de mettre des sous sans que ça
dégrade leur taux de déficit
deuxièmement il faut effectivement avoir
une politique monétaire telle que le
fait monsieur Draghi et il faut des
réformes structurelles pays par pays ne
l'oublions jamais c'est les trois à la
fois donc si on les a pas l'un des trois
ça ne marchera pas Robert Rochefort
merci vous restez avec nous puisque nous
poursuivons sur l'actualité économique
avec un rapport remis au gouvernement
sur la politique du logement qui propose
une refonte des aides personnelles au
logement la fin de mesure de soutien au
HLM ou encore la suppression de la prime
pour travaux de rénovation énergétique
alors les auteurs de ce rapport ce sont
le Conseil Général de l'environnement et
du développement durable l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales et
l'inspection générale des finances ils
avaient reçu pour mission donc de
scruter la politique du logement en
France à la fois qui est considéré comme
très pour les finances publiques 2% du
PIB et aussi dénoncer pour son manque
d'efficacité
à leur choix les mesures proposées en
tout cas vont sans doute proposer
provoquer de vivre critiques oui dans le
collimateur des trois des trois
inspections vous l'avez dit les aides au
logement notamment ça n'est pas une
surprise ça fait plusieurs années déjà
que l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales pointe le problème l'efficacité
sociale des aides au logement l'APL
notamment à fortement diminué alors que
leur poids est toujours aussi lourd dans
les finances publiques le rapport
propose donc un meilleur ciblage et une
attribution en fonction du taux d'effort
des foyers plus se loger pèse lourd dans
le budget plus important doivent être
les aides autre pistes l'argent de ces
aides devraient éviter d'être dépensé
pour des ménages disposant d'un certain
niveau de patrimoine et notamment ceux
qui ont déjà un logement résidant
secondaire ou investissement locatif
mais aussi pour des étudiants qui sont
encore rattachés au foyer fiscal de
leurs parents sur ce sur ces sujets
tremblement de terre vont plancher dès
la semaine prochaine de façon générale
ce que pointent ce rapport tenu bien à
l'abri depuis l'été dernier c'est le
manque absolu de cohérence des
politiques de logement qui concernent
trop d'acteurs qui consacrent la
prééminence de l'État par rapport au
collectivités locales et qui a souvent
tendance à se résumer à des dispositifs
de soutien parfois contradictoires entre
eux par exemple les dispositifs de
soutien à la construction ils devraient
logiquement aider à la sortie de terre
de logement là où les besoins sont
avérés dit le rapport mais de fait il
servent surtout à soutenir le secteur du
bâtiment dont l'activité et
consommatrice de main d'oeuvre et de
matériaux fabriqués en France résultat
on se retrouve avec un phénomène de
surproduction de logements dans
certaines zones et une pénurie de
logement là où la demande est tendue
pour résumer s'il existe un domaine où
faire des économies pour être allés de
pair avec Gagny en efficacité c'est bien
celui de la politique du logement un
rapport qui devrait en tout cas
alimenter les réflexions avant la
préparation du budget 2016
à leur choix merci faire des économies
pour être plus efficace vous croyez à
cela vous cet exemple du logement est
spectaculaire c'est le cas dans beaucoup
beaucoup de politiques en France on
dépense beaucoup d'argent et on n'a pas
l'efficacité qu'on voulait alors sur le
logement deux idées très simples
toute la capacité d'argent que nous
mettons en place aboutit à quelque chose
qui est en fait de favoriser la
spéculation sur les prix des logements
c'est à dire que
en solvabilise et donc on fait monter
les prix mais on ne fait pas on ne
permet pas la construction là où il y a
des vrais besoins et c'est ça le vrai
drame parce que la politique du logement
coûte extrêmement cher et on n'a jamais
aussi peu construit en France qu'en 2014
les aides il faut effectivement les
déplacer il faut aujourd'hui les placer
sur ce qui permettra de construire là où
il y a des besoins et il y a deux ou
trois idées très simples premièrement il
faut que le prix le prix de la terre le
prix du foncier comme on dit dans les
endroits en tension soit du prix qui
soit pas cher et il faut pour cela
peut-être avec des des fonds publics de
l'État qu'on permet aux collectivités
territoriales aux établissements publics
aux entreprises qui ont plein de friches
et plein de terrains de les rendre sur
le marché en les mettant à un prix
extrêmement bas de façon à ce qu'on
puisse construire le moins cher possible
deuxièmement réduire les normes
troisièmement réduire les délais parce
que c'est trop long en France entre le
moment où on décide de construire le
moment où on construit vraiment et
quatrièmement le modèle d'accord avec la
politique du gouvernement sur ces points
là plus la loi
attendez pour l'instant il y a pas de
politique il y a un rapport on va bien
voir maintenant indirectement vous me
parlez de le Macron si je comprends pas
parce que le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est le lois Macron
la loi Macron la France va mal
économiquement quand un malade va mal
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on peut faire
de la chirurgie lourde mais c'est
effectivement invasif et le malade on
sait pas s'il va en sortir mais bon la
loi Macron c'est on fait des piqûres
hypodermiques c'est-à-dire vous savez on
fait plein de petites piqûres et on
pense qu'avec plein de petites piqûres
ça va suffisamment de produits pour
guérir le malade des fois on peut pas
faire autrement c'est ce que fait le loi
Macron la question c'est de savoir si le
nombre de petites piqûres qu'on va faire
au final vont être suffisantes pour
relancer ou pas le malade je n'en suis
pas sûr et évidemment du coup il manque
les grandes mesures tout le monde le
sait bien en l'occurrence malgré tout
est-ce que par rapport à ces petites
piqûres et ses petites mesures il faut
être contre non je pense que il y a des
choses qui sont positives dans la loi
Macron je pense par exemple à
l'actionnariat salarial et à cet égard
oui ça va dans un sens qui est positif
mais c'est absolument loin loin loin
loin d'être suffisant et ça ne suffirait
pas à elle toute seule cette loi pour
relancer l'activité dans notre pays
merci beaucoup Robert Rochefort d'avoir
accepté notre invitation